it's a poll what do you guys do to
actually get out of the way when you're
testing with the user you know what what
questions do you ask them or what
statements do you give them to make sure
they're comfortable just taking the
product as it is hmm so by far the most
important one is to make sure that the
user knows that we are not testing them
we are testing the software we will
actually often make that just a hundred
percent explicit so we are not testing
you we are testing the program if you
feel like you're doing something wrong
you're not our program is doing
something wrong then we kind of step
back and let them start using the
software the other thing that we do
during tests which is really important
is to have the user think aloud so
thinking aloud is a little bit different
than just talking or just thinking right
one of the great best ways that I found
to get a user to think aloud or to
understand what thinking aloud is is to
ask them how many windows they have in
their house or their apartment and most
people will say oh four and you go okay
well hang on
walk me through the process of how you
got there many user will go well I guess
they're you know two in the kitchen and
then I turned left and there oh there's
another little one there so it's three
and then I go upstairs and I guess
there's a couple windows on the
staircase you're like okay that's the
process that we want you to go through
right we want to know what you're
thinking as you're thinking what you're
noticing what you're understanding when
you realize something we want to know
that right and then as the test goes on
you kind of keep poking them and keep
prompting them yeah I think it's start
to get frustrated and you go back and
remind them again this is great
information for us you're doing nothing
wrong this is exactly what we want to
know yep